LET ME KNOW ON TWITTER
@BretBaier.
YOU CAN USE THE HASHTAG
#SpecialReport
OR ON FACEBOOK AT
Facebook.com/BretBaierSR.
THE LIST KEEPS GROWING TIDE OF
COUNTRIES EXPELLING RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS OVER THE POISONING OF
A FORMER KREMLIN SPY IN ENGLAND.
AUSTRALIA, BELGIUM, IRELAND,
MOLDOVA MADE THE MOVE TODAY.
SO DID THE NATO ALLIANCE.
GETTING MORE REACTIONS NIGHT
HERE AT HOME AS WELL.
KEVIN CORKE IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE LATEST.
>> WE ARE APPLYING PRESSURE.
>> HOURS AFTER ANNOUNCING HIS
EXPULSION OF RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS
FOLLOWING THE DANGEROUS NERVE
AGENT ATTACK ON THE RUSSIAN
FOREIGN AGENT ON BRITISH SOIL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE BY
TELEPHONE WITH SEVERAL
INTERNATIONAL LEADERS, NOTABLY
CANADA'S JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
FRANCE'S MACRON, AND GERMANY'S
ANGELA MERKEL.
MORE THAN 100 RUSSIANS EXPELLED
FROM COUNTRIES ACROSS THE GLOBE.
>> WE ARE ENCOURAGING AND
WORKING WITH ALLIES AND PARTNERS
TO DO SO.
YOU'VE SEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF COUNTRIES STEP UP AND
JOINED THE UNITED STATES AND THE
EFFORT.
>> DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM MATTIS
TOLD REPORTERS THAT THE
POISONING AMOUNTED TO ATTEMPTED
MURDER BY THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, SAYING RUSSIAN HAS
CHOSEN TO BE A STRATEGIC
COMPETITOR EVEN TO THE POINT OF
RECKLESS ACTIVITY.
NATO LEADERS CALLED THE
EXPULSION'S A CLEAR SIGN THAT
THE RUSSIANS PLANNED TO SOW
DISCORD IN THE WEST AND IT WON'T
WORK.
>> I THINK RUSSIA HAS
UNDERESTIMATED THE UNITY OF NATO
ALLIES.
>> THE KREMLIN WARNED IT WOULD
ACT IN RECIPROCAL FASHION.
>> Translator: 11 OR TWO
DIPLOMATS ARE ASKED TO LEAVE,
WHISPERING APOLOGIES, WE
KNOW FOR SURE THIS IS THE
RESULT OF COLOSSAL PRESSURE AND
COLOSSAL BLACKMAIL WHICH ARE
USED BY WASHINGTON AT THE MAIN
INSTRUMENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAS
REMAINED SILENT FOR HOURS ON THE
DECISION TO EXPEL THE RUSSIANS
AND CLOSE THE CONSULATE FACILITY
NEAR SEATTLE.
PASSING ON HIS PENCHANT FOR
TWEETING ON RUSSIA, ITS
RESPONSE, EVEN THEY STORMY
DANIELS SAGA.
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S
OFFICES UNDER PRESSURE TO
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS RELATED TO THE
REVIEW OF SENIOR ADVISOR JARED
KUSHNER'S COMPLIANCE WITH ETHICS
LAWS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ARE LOOKING
INTO GAUCHER'S MEETINGS WITH
EXECUTIVES FROM TWO COMPANIES
THAT LATER LOANED BILLIONS TO
HIS FAMILY'S BUSINESS.
THIS IS HAPPENING AS THE STORMY
DANIELS SAGA CONTINUES.
HER CAMP IS SUING THE
PRESIDENT'S PRIVATE ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN, CLAIMING HE HAS